Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
À votre avis, combien de personnes
en France se déclarent fatiguées ?
Un million ? 10 millions ?
Plus de 30 millions.
Une personne sur deux en France
se déclare fatiguée
et les médecins avec qui je travaille
me disent
qu’en France c’est la première cause
de consultation en médecine générale,
devant les douleurs articulaires.
On pourrait faire un petit sondage
tout de suite,
entre nous dans la salle : qui n’a pas
été fatigué du tout de l’année ?
Voilà.
Mais je ne vais pas vraiment
vous parler de la fatigue.
Je vais parler des remèdes à la fatigue.
Aujourd’hui, on va parler,
ce soir, d’énergie,
de cette énergie qui nous anime.
C’est intéressant
parce que tous les peuples, ou presque,
dans l’histoire de l’humanité,
lui ont donné un nom.
On appelle ça le «Qi» en Chine,
«Ki », au Japon, « Prana » en Inde,
« Viriditas » en médecine hildegardienne,
«Pneuma» dans la Grèce antique
et «Ruah » en médecine hébraïque
et en médecine arabe.
On ne sait pas la mesurer
scientifiquement,
ça sera peut-être le cas plus tard.
En revanche, tous ensemble ici,
on sent très très bien
quand elle augmente dans notre corps
et quand elle baisse dans notre corps.
Et on voit bien qu’il y a tout un tas
de paramètres extérieurs et intérieurs
qui vont avoir une incidence
sur cette énergie qui nous anime.
Les paramètres extérieurs d'abord.
Le cadre de vie.
On voit bien qu'il y a des environnements
qui nous stimulent.
Quand on choisit un travail,
quand on choisit un lieu de vie,
en général,
on les choisit de cette manière.
Et on sait très bien qu’il y en a d’autres
qui nous font tout le contraire.
Autre paramètre extérieur important :
le lien qu’on entretient avec les autres.
Le lien qu’on entretient
avec notre famille, nos amis,
nos collègues, nos amours.
Et là encore, il y a des relations
qui nourrissent
et il y en a d’autres qui nous nuisent.
Ces deux paramètres constituent
ce qu’on appelle le bien-être,
tout ce qui, de l’extérieur,
va venir impacter votre énergie.
Mais il y a aussi des paramètres
intérieurs à notre corps.
Le premier, dont on parlera un petit peu
plus aujourd’hui, vous l’aurez compris,
c'est l'alimentation.
C’est vraiment cette alimentation
qui va nous donner
cette première force d’énergie.
Et ce n’est pas juste
une histoire de calories.
Mais il n’y a pas que ça,
il y a aussi le mouvement.
Parce qu’une fois qu’on a cette énergie,
il faut bien qu’elle circule.
Et puis, il y a le repos, parce qu’on
ne peut pas toujours être à fond.
Il faut aussi qu’on puisse se ménager
des moments plus calmes.
Des moments plus calmes
pour traverser une journée.
pour vivre notre saison
le long d’une année et pour traverser
notre existence dans la vie.
Tout ça, ça constitue la vitalité.
Donc tout ce qui va naître de l’intérieur.
Tous ces paramètres, ensemble,
vont être très importants
pour notre performance dans la vie.
Alors moi, j’ai envie de vous parler
aujourd’hui plus particulièrement
de ce lien qui existe
entre l’alimentation et l’énergie.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ça me touche à titre personnel.
Adolescente, mes parents m’ont mise
au régime, j’ai dû perdre du poids.
C’était nécessaire.
C’était nécessaire et...
quelque part, une souffrance aussi,
parce qu’on m’a tout interdit, ou presque.
Enfin, tout ce que j'aimais.
Mais le plus dur, ce n'était pas ça.
Ce n’était même pas de retirer
la crème fraîche d’Isigny
ou le beurre salé,
parce que c’était ma culture
et les souvenirs de la cuisine
de ma grand-mère.
Le vrai problème pour moi,
c’était de me sentir fatiguée.
Fatiguée, alors que j’étais toute jeune
et que, quand on rêve
de la première place en tout
et que le corps ne suit pas,
c’est quand même hyper difficile.
Je m’en suis sortie.
J’ai perdu du poids.
Je pouvais enfin porter des robes
au baptême de mes cousines
sans passer des heures à pleurer
dans la salle de bain
en me disant que je ne ressemblais à rien.
Et j'avais des bons résultats à l'école.
Mais je me suis fait une promesse.
Je me suis dit : «Émilie, dans la vie,
tu trouveras le moyen d’avoir du plaisir
à table, parce que c’est ta raison d’être.
Tu auras de l’énergie tous les jours,
parce que tu as énormément de rêves.
Et puis, tout ça dans un corps
qui te ressemblera,
dans lequel tu te sentiras bien,
parce que tu as une certitude,
c’est que, de corps, tu n’en auras qu’un.
Donc il vaut mieux
que tu t’entendes avec.»
Mais l’Eureka, il arrive plus tard.
C’est un voyage, un voyage
au Japon qui changera tout.
Au Japon, il y a un dicton,
qui dit : «Ichigo ichi-e»,
une rencontre, une chance.
Cette rencontre, ça sera pour
moi un changement de vie.
Aujourd’hui, je suis chef de cuisine,
comme l’a dit Camille.
Je forme des chefs
à la cuisine énergétique.
Cette cuisine qui me vient du Japon,
de la Chine, de l’Inde
et de toutes les cultures
qui m’ont intéressée
et qui ont entretenu ce lien particulier
entre l’alimentation et l’énergie.
Qian Jin Yao, un grand médecin
de l’Antiquité chinoise,
disait la chose suivante :
«Celui qui ne sait pas manger
ne sait pas vivre.»
Parce que ça peut peut-être vous étonner,
mais en fait, même en mangeant,
on peut perdre son énergie
au lieu de la gagner.
Une tomate biologique pousse l’hiver
dans une serre
et traverse toute l’Europe
pour se retrouver dans votre assiette.
Quelle énergie !
Un petit plat préparé avec amour,
en famille, le week-end,
sera réchauffé le lendemain,
le surlendemain
ou à la fin de la semaine,
avec un passage au micro-ondes,
voire un passage au congélateur.
Quelle énergie !
Au contraire.
Imaginez que vous avez parfois
tellement d’énergie dans l’assiette
que vous n’êtes pas
en capacité de la digérer.
Êtes-vous tous capables de bien digérer
une énorme assiette de légumes crus,
même en plein hiver,
un bol de graines germées
ou même juste des fruits frais
découpés en dessert ?
Ben, moi qui ne suis pas bien vieille,
mais ça, je n’y arrive déjà plus
sans avoir le ventre qui gonfle
et énormément sommeil
devant mon ordinateur l’après-midi.
Donc, parfois on a l’impression
qu’il y a des repas énergisants,
qui nous donnent de l’énergie,
mais en fait ils nous fatiguent.
Alors, on ferait peut-être mieux
de se laisser tenter
par un petit couscous aux épices
d’Orient, bien plus équilibré.
En fait, la plupart du temps on pense
ne pas manger les bonnes choses,
alors qu’en fait, le vrai problème,
c’est qu’on les mange mal.
Et pour ça, vous pensez -
Je vais vous donner une bonne nouvelle.
Une première bonne nouvelle.
J'en ai deux.
La première bonne nouvelle,
c’est qu’il n’y a pas d’interdit
en cuisine énergétique.
En fait -
excusez-moi -
En fait, vous pouvez tout vous permettre.
Ce qui va être le plus important, ça va
être de trouver les bonnes occasions.
Par exemple, vous êtes gourmand comme moi,
vous avez envie de manger un gâteau.
Eh bien, à l’heure du goûter,
ça fera tout à fait l’affaire.
Alors qu’à la fin d’un repas,
ça va peut-être vous alourdir.
Finalement, l’alimentation,
c’est une des clés les plus simples
pour nous redonner cette énergie.
Ce qui m’amène à
une deuxième bonne nouvelle.
On est tous dans cette salle autonome
pour pouvoir agir sur notre vitalité.
Tous autonomes,
et ce n’est pas une question de budget.
La seule chose à savoir, c’est qu’il faut
prendre des bonnes décisions,
dans cinq domaines.
Premier domaine :
la sélection des produits.
Quand je choisis un produit, j’ai envie
de trouver de l’énergie à l’intérieur.
Je vous ai dit tout à l’heure
que l’homme a de l’énergie.
Mais il n’est pas le seul.
On trouve cette énergie
dans le monde du vivant en général,
c’est à dire dans les plantes,
dans les animaux.
Et que va faire le mangeur ?
Il va aller chercher cette énergie-là.
La meilleure énergie qu’on puisse trouver,
c’est dans l’univers du sauvage.
On n’a pas tous la chance
d’avoir un copain chasseur
qui nous ramène son cuissot de sanglier.
Mais on peut aller aux champignons,
on peut aller cueillir de l’ail des ours,
aller pêcher des moules.
Et si on n’a pas accès au sauvage,
on a peut-être un jardin derrière
la maison où on peut planter des radis.
On a peut-être une AMAP dans le quartier.
On a peut-être aussi un marché
de producteurs.
Au Japon et en Chine,
les mères de famille se levaient tôt
traditionnellement
pour préparer les bento
des maris et des enfants.
Elles allaient au marché, car elles
savaient qu’elles y trouvaient quoi ?
Des produits frais, de saison, avec
énormément d'énergie vitale à l'intérieur.
Ici, à Metz, vous avez un marché couvert
face à la cathédrale
du mardi au samedi à partir de 7 h.
Deuxième point important,
une fois que j’ai trouvé mon produit,
c’est comment je le conserve.
En fait, ce qu’il faut faire,
c’est lui faire croire
qu’il est toujours dans la nature,
tout faire pour qu’il
ne s’en rende pas compte :
garder la terre dans les racines,
même si ça salit le frigo,
garder le vert des poireaux au marché,
même si ça dépasse du panier.
On va laver, effeuiller, couper,
cuire au dernier moment.
Mariner préservera
l’énergie de l’ingrédient.
Déshydrater concentrera
Fermenter augmentera
l’énergie de l’ingrédient.
Troisième point : transformer son produit.
Et là, on va suivre la vie d’un poireau.
Qui dans la salle a acheté
un poireau le mois dernier ?
Waouh !
Je suis contente !
Super !
Comment vous le découpez votre poireau ?
En rondelles - ouais, je vois déjà ça,
comme ça, en rondelles.
Je ne vais pas demander qui fait
partie de la team Rondelle, comme moi.
Pendant longtemps, j’ai coupé
mon poireau ainsi,
Mais le poireau, il pousse comment ?
Comme ça.
Le poireau, le bambou, l'asperge, poussent
verticalement dans la longueur.
C’est pour ça qu’en Asie,
quand on coupe les légumes,
on les coupe de cette manière.
Tous ces légumes, on va suivre
le sens de la pousse
parce qu’on veut préserver l’énergie
le plus longtemps possible.
Quatrième point important
et stratégique : l’association.
Les jardiniers, ce sont des poètes.
Ils ont un mot très sympa
pour raconter ça.
Ils parlent des plantes compagnes.
Les plantes compagnes,
c’est beau, n’est-ce pas ?
Donc -
(Cris dans le public)
plus tard, les questions (Rit) -
Aujourd’hui donc - je reprends
le fil de ma pensée -
Plante compagne.
Savez-vous que le basilic est
la plante compagne de la tomate ?
Intéressant.
En fait, le basilic va repousser
les aleurodes,
les petites mouches blanches
qu’on va trouver dans les serres.
Et en même temps, il protège du mildiou.
Que fait la tomate ?
Elle va protéger par son feuillage
la pousse du basilic
en créant comme un petit microclimat.
Tomate plus basilic.
Voilà une association que nos amis
italiens connaissent bien.
Mais on a aussi des associations
digestives en cuisine.
On en a des tonnes.
On sait par exemple que les légumineuses,
si on les cuisine avec de l’ail et du
persil, on évitera les ballonnements.
Dernier point important : la dégustation.
Les médecins parlent
de chrono-alimentation.
En gros, le matin on se lève,
on a un maximum d'énergie.
Normalement, si tout va bien.
Cette énergie est aussi
au service de votre digestion.
Ça veut dire que le matin, quand on se
lève, on peut tout digérer ou presque.
Alors le gras, le sucre, on y va,
on se fait plaisir.
Par contre, plus ça va passer,
plus la journée va s’écouler
et moins on aura d’énergie,
donc moins on aura d’énergie digestive.
C'est pour ça qu'en général
on essaie de manger léger.
Et tous ici, on va se rappeler d’un dîner
où on se sera tout permis, ou presque,
et on aura passé une nuit difficile.
Donc, si je résume.
Vous êtes autonome.
Pour restaurer cette énergie :
cinq étapes clés.
Première étape : sélection des produits.
Deuxième étape :
conservation des produits.
Troisième étape :
transformation des produits.
Quatrième étape :
association des produits.
Cinquième étape :
dégustation des produits.
Et selon Qian Jin Yao, celui qui
ne sait pas manger ne sait pas vivre.
C'est important de savoir déguster.
Dans la vie,
vous aurez plusieurs enfants,
je vous le souhaite.
Vous aurez possiblement plusieurs jobs
et également, peut-être,
plusieurs lieux de vie,
voire plusieurs femmes
ou plusieurs enfants.
Mais de corps, vous n'en aurez qu'un.
Ce corps, c’est comme un véhicule
qui peut vous emmener partout
à condition qu’on en prenne soin
et qu’on l’écoute.
Sortir du cadre, ce n'est pas forcément
changer ses habitudes.
On sait très bien qu'on finit
toujours par les reprendre.
En revanche, si vous êtes
gourmand, comme moi,
et que vous voyez,
ou que vous faites les yeux doux,
à une petite tarte aux mirabelles,
alors, faites-vous plaisir !
Faites-vous plaisir,
mais dites-vous d’abord :
«Mais à quelle heure, en fait,
je vais mieux l’apprécier ?»
Et puis :
«Où vais-je m’installerais pour ça ?»
«Et avec qui je la partage,
cette tarte ?»
Hippocrate disait que notre alimentation,
c'était notre première médecine.
Alors j’ai une question pour vous :
qui dans cette salle, a envie de faire
un adieu définitif à la fatigue ?
Yeah !
On a tous envie de ça.
Le bonheur,
il paraît que c’est une décision.
Alors moi, j’ai envie qu’ensemble,
on se fasse la promesse
de la prendre ce soir.
Ce soir, on décide de redevenir
les architectes, les bâtisseurs,
les créateurs de notre énergie
retrouvée grâce à notre alimentation.
(Applaudissements)